Mal gucken gehts jetzt?
Ah, jetzt gehts!
Also 6900 scheint anscheinend das größte zu sein wo man auf Twitch streben kann würde
ich mal sagen.
6900, so guck mal man konnte sich doch den Kram hier irgendwie anzeigen lassen.
Video Stats, ja 6900, jetzt haben wir huge quali haben wir am start.
Guck mal, der Karsten ist am start, krasse Banger, erstmal voll im Stream, vier weiber
im Swimming Pool, aber nice nice, ok das finde ich gut.
Ich zeige euch jetzt mal was Leute, Speedtest, passt mal auf, big brain time, Pfeil fährt,
bam, passt auf, passt auf, seht ihr das hier, Pog, huge, warum sind denn die Emotes heute
so groß?
Siehst ja gar nix, hier 4025 Mbit, massive Poggers und hier 41, 42 ab, gut jetzt, jetzt
back zwei, ne, es lags ein bisschen weil ich uploade, alles kein Problem, Call of Duty
Problems, Störungen bei Call of Duty, Moment, allesstörungen.de hat ne Seite für Call of
Duty, warum, bloß 96 danke, was kostet der Spaß, 80,98 Euro, also ich brauch mehr Subs
dass ich mir das leisten kann, easy subs easy live, also 81 Euro kostet der Kram, das ist
dabei, 400 down, 20 ab, Power Upload macht 40 ab, Fernseh, also der Kabelanschluss ist
dabei, ähm, gut Flatrate muss man heute nicht mehr erwohnen, Fernseh, Stells, ich hab heute
ein riesen Paket gekriegt von Unity Media und davon hab ich nix ausgepackt außer diese
komische Connectbox, ist das, dies Teil da und das hat mich, das hat mich schon mal Massive
Jebaited am Anfang, das Ding hat mich Massive Jebaited, weil ich hab's angemacht, hab mich
eingeloggt, bin halt auf die Adresse und da stand dann da alles verbunden, Wlan an, Internet
an, sonst was, aber online ging nicht, äh, Collox oder Krolox, Stufe 1, huge big brain
sub, ähm, zumindest stand halt da, ich bin online, alles gut, aber es war nicht online,
ich konnte nichts pingen und ich hab dann erst gedacht, ok, woran liegt das, ich hab
ja in der Box von Unity Media, ne, waren irgendwie 3 verschiedene Geräte drin, irgendein komischer
Verstärker, wo ich keine Ahnung hab, wozu es gut sein soll, irgendeine komische Box
zum Fernseh gucken und aufnehmen und halt, und halt das Ding, der Router, da steht lustigerweise
Modem drauf, was aber eigentlich nicht stimmt, weil das ist ein Router, also ein Multifunktionsgerät
um mal zurückzukommen auf mein Video von vor ein paar Tagen, äh, ist überhaupt kein
Modem, ist natürlich ein Modem drin, aber es ist noch viel mehr als ein Modem, und ich
brauch davon nichts, ich brauch nur das Modem, den ganzen anderen Kram brauch man nicht,
da ist so ein, ich hab keine Ahnung, für das hier da ist ehrlich gesagt, fair, Multimedia,
Multimedia, fair, Stärker, Moment, Multimedia, da kannste mal, fair, der da, ich weiß überhaupt
nicht, was ich damit soll, was ist das überhaupt, ja, so schwarz ist es bei mir, was, was ist
das überhaupt, und wann, wann sollte ich es benutzen, das ist kein WLAN Repeater, Blödsinn,
nee, hast du eigentlich die Bürsten oder die Privatvariante, ich hab die Privatvariante,
ich hab keine Ahnung, was das ist, das Ding ist doch zum extrahieren des TV-Signals, weiß
ich nicht, keine Ahnung, also ich hab, äh, meine zwei TV-Karten da dran angeschlossen
und die gehen nach wie vor, ohne, ohne Änderungen, ja, moin, deine Meinung, dass bei einer 4K-Leitung
abends zu 100 und montags mittags 180 durchgebrannt, nicht, meinst du bei dir jetzt, ja das sackt
man natürlich, stört dich DS Lite nicht, doch mich stört DS Lite, deswegen hab ich
auch kein DS Lite, mir gibt's kein DS Lite, ich hab noch einen kompletten vollwertigen
IPv4 Anschluss, trotz Upgrade, ich hab mir jetzt von denen vor dem Upgrade 50 mal bestätigen
lassen, dass ich IPv4 behalte und war dann auch so am Ende, zumindest ich hab keine Ahnung,
was für das Ding ist, ich weiß nicht mal, was man da mit macht, Multimedia Verstärker,
brauch ich nicht, hab sie nicht angeschlossen, geht auch so, alles wunderbar und was ich
im Leben nicht anschließen werde, ist das da, es war auch dabei, so eine komische Box
von Unimedia, ich vermute mal, die ist zum Fernseh gucken, aber wisst ihr, was ich mit
der machen werde, die werde ich auf den Dachboden stellen und nie wieder anrühren, verwende
ich nicht, total crap, das einzige, was ich brauche von Ultimedia ist das Modem, Skatanschluss,
ja ich mein, ja gut, überall, warum kann ich da, hab ich das richtig gesehen, man kann
da ein Telefon anschließen, oder seh ich das jetzt falsch, Telefon, Telefon, warum will
ich denn an einem Fernsehen ein Telefon anschließen, das ist mal Big Brain Time von Unimedia, warum
genau will ich im Fernsehen ein Telefon anschließen, das ist Router und Resiefer, ja warum, ich
hab doch schon einen Router, ich hab doch diese komische Connectbox, ok, was auch immer,
wir hinterfragen das nicht weiter, ich werd's eh nicht verwenden und wisst ihr, was richtig
nice ist, was ich gerade, oh sorry Leute, tut mir leid, tut mir leid, Router, den Router
werd ich nicht verwenden, aber wisst ihr, was ich gesehen hab, was richtig poggers ist,
Connectbox Bridge Mode, seit diesem oder seit zwei Monaten oder so, kann man die Connectbox
in Bridge Mode betreiben und das heißt, ich kann einfach alles mit meinem MikroTik Router
machen, ich weiß zwar noch nicht, wie man das einrichtet, aber das geht bestimmt, das
geht bestimmt und dann bin ich komplett den ganzen Crap von Unimedia los, dann ist das
einfach nur ein stinknormales Modem, aber dann geht glaube ich Telefon nicht mehr, benutz
ich ja auch das Telefon gar nicht von Unimedia, also aktuell hab ich das so, ich kann euch
das ja mal kurz erklären, wie ich mir das gedacht hab, ob's funktioniert, sieht man
dann natürlich erst nach ein paar Monaten, und zwar aktuell hab ich, danke für die Subs,
den haben wir hier, Teinsa, Twitch Prime, huge big brain play, Fritzi, 14 HD, auch
ein Twitch Prime Sub, big brain alle heute und maximale Frames pro Sekunde natürlich,
also ich hab, bei Unimedia, also ich hab einmal Unimedia Fly 400 an der Name schon alleine,
schon Fly 400, da ist dabei ein Kabelanschluss für 2099, dann Fly, das ist der jetzt noch
dabei, so, das ist quasi Internet und Fernseh, also, so, und dann hab ich für diesen Telefon
Crampel hab ich bei Easybell den kleinsten Anschluss, den's gibt, nicht Internet und
Telefon, ich will nur Telefon, Privatkunden, Telefon, das Ding hab ich hier für 2099,
im Monat, das hab ich gemacht aus dem Grund, weil ich keinen Bock habe, abhängig zu sein
von meinem Internet Provider, 3play, Fly 400, triple play, triple play Fly 400, zumindest
hab ich mir extra den Kram hier gebucht und meine Rufnummer dahin portieren lassen, weil
es ist immer kacke, seinen Internet Provider zu wechseln, wenn da auch automatisch das
portierende Rufnummer dranhängt, das ist immer mehr Stress als es irgendwie sein müsste,
deswegen hab ich es jetzt so gemacht, meine Telefonnummer hab ich einmal zu diesem Anbieter
hier portiert, ich bezahle 2,99€ zusätzlich im Monat, und da geht einfach, ich telefoniere
nicht viel, ich werde noch nicht viel angerufen und dann ist das optimal, das kostet 2,99€
nochmal obendrauf, deswegen kann ich einfach meine Connectbox, mir gerade eingefallen,
kann einfach meine Connectbox in Bridge Mode setzen, die Beta, die sagt 38GB oder so,
oh fuck, ich glaube ich hab meine Festplatte voll gemacht mit Videoaufnahmen vorhin, entweder,
Monkeys.
So und das werde ich morgen mal ausprobieren glaube ich, jetzt den, ich werde meinen Router
umstellen, äh nicht umstellen, ich werde meine Connectbox umstellen auf Bridge, wie
macht man dann mit Mikrotik, wie macht man mit dem Mikrotik Router dann die Einwahl,
ich hab keine Ahnung ehrlich gesagt.
Es gibt auch mittlerweile wieder das Modem was, ne, also ich hab nur, ich hab, ich kann
die Connectbox umstellen auf Modebetrieb, das wäre natürlich am besten, da muss ich
nichts extra nochmal schicken lassen.
Ja ok, wie auch immer, keine Ahnung, aber das werde ich mal ausprobieren und dann ist
der ganze Crap raus, das komische Unity Media WLAN, die versuchen einem standardmäßig
so ein komisches Gäste-WLAN aufzuschwatzen, wo man dann irgendwelche Leute die auf der
Straße rumlaufen im Handy in seinem WLAN drinne hat und so was, ganz komisches Zeug
und alles weg und wenn es sich nicht ausschalten lässt, dann kommt irgendwie, dann kommt die
Box in irgendeine Alu-Alukiste, wo das WLAN nicht mehr rausgeht, also ich hab kein Bock
irgendwie Leute in meinem WLAN zu haben, ich weiß es ist ein eigenes WLAN, aber allein
schon das die auf meinem Router drauf sind, ist mir irgendwie nicht so ganz geheuer.
Aluhut, ja der Aluhut kommt auf den Router drauf, Zelda Tab leider ist das nicht mehr
da, die haben das glaube ich gelöscht das Video hier, es ist Batman, Contains Nintendo
Content.
Ich hab übrigens gerade mit dem Tyler ein bisschen Modern Warfare gespielt, übelst
neiße Runde, 45, 45, 9 oder so, übelst bam, bam, alles weggeklatscht.
Könntest du das Ding nicht flashen, nee die Connectbox kannst du nicht flashen, die Connectbox
kannst du nicht flashen, ja jetzt wenn ich gerade mal online bin, könnte ich eigentlich
mal das einkaufen, was ich im letzten Stream einkaufen wollte, 10, 10, wenn du 10 MBit
Upload hast, ist vollkommen ausreichend zum Streamen, vollkommen ausreichend, sehr körperbetont
irgendwie, ich weiß nicht ob es gibt Grills die wirklich so am Strand rumlaufen, ich weiß
nicht, ich könnte mir vorstellen das wäre den meisten ein bisschen zu freizügig am
Strand, naja was auch immer, das wollen wir jetzt eigentlich, wollte ich das jetzt nicht
bestellen, mindestens 25, nee guck mal, wenn du streamen willst, du kannst mit viel weniger
streamen, das Maximum an Bitrate, guck mal hier, das Maximum an Bitrate was geht auf
Twitch ist 6,9 MBit, das reicht locker was du hast, locker, ich wollte mir nämlich für
mein NAS gebasteln, für mein NAS Selbstbauversuchsding, wollte ich mir einen SATA 3 Portmultiplier
kaufen und gucken ob das ordentlich funktioniert, hier sowas da, das geht eigentlich mit der
Musik ab, passt bei der Lautstärke ja, es sollte noch mehr, also ich hab es gerade mal
gestellt auf 12 MBit, das war zu viel, das war zu viel, so viel ging nicht, da hat er
runter encoded, ich brauche nämlich einen SATA 3 Portmultiplier, wenn es das gibt wäre
echt nice, das ist nur SATA 2 oder SATA 3, tatsächlich doch, ich glaube das wäre nämlich
echt nice sowas, 6 GBit, ja das ist das Richtige, sowas hier wollte ich mir mal bestellen, zwei
Stück, da brauchen die da versandt nach Deutschland, Shipping, Leute es ist so krass oder, dass
du was aus China bestellen kannst und es kostet dich aus China was zu bestellen 51 Cent, 51
Cent aus China oder alternativ mit DHL für 34 Euro, ja EMS Paket nehmen wir dann, kommt
an am 18.10, reicht doch, drei Wochen easy, gut oder alternativ mit Turkey Post, also
quasi Truthahn, das würde ich dann nehmen, Germany Perfekt, kauf mal gleich mal, kauf
mal gleich mal, vier Stück, add card, kann man sicher einfach so einen Card adden, geil
bitte ich mal nachher bestellen eine Runde, das ist Hardcore subventioniert die Versandkosten,
letztens die USB Kabel die ich bestellt habe, da haben 50 USB Kabel 46 Euro gekostet inklusive
DHL versandt, das heißt ich habe das Ding, ich habe ein USB Kabel 1,5 Meter, oder ein
Meter, egal ist doch scheiß egal ob 1 oder 1,5 Meter, für unter 1 Euro gekriegt ist
ein Mikro USB Kabel mit Adapter dabei auf USB C für unter 1 Euro, 50, ja bam, 50 USB
Kabel, ja warum denn auch nicht, warum auch nicht, ich meine wer braucht keine 50 USB
Kabel, warum 50 Stück, weil ich für nächste Zeit definitiv genug USB Kabel haben wollte,
ich wollte einfach nur mal sicher gehen, dass ich nie out of USB Kabel runne, merkwürdiges
Deutsch, der Umwelt zuliebe, das auch, ich meine ich könnte mir 50 mal 1 USB Kabel bestellen
oder einmal 50 USB Kabel, das ist natürlich dann einfach viel umweltbewusster, so sieht
es aus, weil ja China bestellen generell so wahnsinnig umweltfreundlich ist, aber was
willst du machen, sowas gibt es hier in Deutschland nicht, wenn ich bei Amazon.de kocke, ich habe
übrigens immer noch eine 1TB NVMe SSD hier rumliegen, die ich noch nicht eingebaut habe,
SATA Port Multiplier mit SATA 3, da gibt es so hä, hä, hä, hä, hä, hä, hä, hä, hä,
hä, hä, hä, hä, hä, hä, hä, hä, hä, hä, hä, hä, hä, hä, hä, hä, hä, hä, hä,
hä, hä, hä, hä, hä, hä, hä, hä, hä, hä, hä, hä, hä, hä, hä, hä, hä, hä,
was für gute kostenlose hostag gibt muss man auf reddit gucken was self-hosted da haben die immer ganz gute sachen oder
du guckst bei wie heißt das low-end talk da gibt es immer von apple und ei irgendwelche guten angebollte
Ist da eigentlich ein großer unterschied zwischen asp.net
Und standard webform, ja riesen unterschied standard webforms verwendet kein mensch mehr
asp.net verwendet auch keiner mehr
asp.net core ist das was zurzeit angesagt ist auch wird auch wird es auch für die nächsten jahre sein
Was hast denn für kabelkabel verschleiß
Eigentlich gar keine alt zu holen aber ich wollte halt genug haben
sub sieb flair
abonniert stufe eins big brain sub
Sub skrimer was macht eigentlich der cute chat heute?
Wo gibt es günstige kat 6a kabel in allen längen und farben mit sicherheit aliexpress
Aliexpress also wenn du da guckst ich netzwerkabel kannst du da super kaufen?
Kannst du gleich so 50er pack holen oder so hast du auch genug
hat der 50 stück 1 bis 2 meter
meistens brauchst du die kurzen
Der kram kostet nichts kannst aber auch bei amazon kaufen die letzten habe ich die letzten paar habe ich bei amazon gekauft
Und das größte teil den größte teil meiner kabel habe ich tatsächlich von der arbeit als wir das rz umgebaut haben
Da habe ich gefragt oder sie haben die mit brauche ich keinen mensch mehr
So jetzt habe ich hier halt einen riesen haufen an netzwerkabeln von ein meter bis bis keine ahnung 20 meter oder so
Ich muss mal gucken dass ich keine subs verpasse
Nix verpasst sebaro hat re-subscribed eats a la lan habe ich übersehen sebaro
Die musik nervt mich gerade
Hast du erfahrungen mit internetleitungen zu hause über lte ne habe ich nicht würde ich aber auch nicht machen es sei dann
Geht gar nicht anders
Ja also das ding werde ich mir nachher bestellen weil ich bin ja immer noch scharf drauf endlich mal mein nass bild
Verwirklichen zu können die auf wort spiele ich gerade nicht aber wie gesagt ich bräuchte mal eine neue revision von den boards und
Leicht geht mit dieser geschichte auch noch was dass man das man auch ein paar platten mehr dran machen kann weil angeblich
Alle gemini leg mainboards sata anschluss support multiplier fähig sind
Also sprich hier macht man das sata kabel vom mainboard dran
Und das macht dann aus einem port halt fünf was halt auch nicht die geschwindigkeit steigert aber
Satta 3 ist schnell genug dafür mehr als eine festplatte
Wann kommen slots dieses glücksspielzeug auf twitch das regert mich irgendwie
Ich verstehe es nicht aber jeder wie er will
Ja auf youtube heute würde ich sagen das video ist ja echt gut angekommen und viele leute das finde ich immer nice
Wenn viele leute die gleichen die gleichen beobachten übrigens habt ihr es hier gesehen hyper clickbait rote kreises thumbnail
Also man sieht ich ich habe es langsam raus wie das funktioniert
Hyper clickbait rote kreises thumbnail also man sieht ich ich habe es langsam raus wie das funktioniert
Ja
Dieses grüne lambda zeichen eine konsole ja
Ihr habt allerdings seit den letzten upgrade irgendwie ihre settings vergessen die war mal irgendwie besser eingestellt
aber ja das ist meine konsole cute konsole ist das
also es ist einfach 3000 mal besser selbst wenn ich cmd eingebe startet er immer noch
den kram warum nicht einfach powershell warum warum schließt sich doch nicht aus
powershell ja also ii ii monkeys wie geht man aus powershell wieder raus so das ist ja
nur das ist ja kein extra das ist ja kein extra shell das ist ja einfach nur ein
ordentliches terminal ja also was man per shortcut auf und zu machen kann was man
ordentlich minimieren kann wo man sachen im hintergrund laufen lassen kann was
escape sequenzen unterstützt was man ordentlich resizing kann alles das was
man mit dem normalen windows terminal eben nicht machen kann das im zweifel
kannst du einfach powershell drin laufen lassen was hältst du davon chrono
bitnet webhosting weiß ich nicht kann mal gucken was halte ich davon wie hast
das gefunden gucken was ich davon halte muss ich mir mal angucken web basic doch
sieht doch ganz ok aus die sache ist bloß die kannst du überhaupt
dort nicht drauf laufen lassen wahrscheinlich nicht oder die werden
doch nur pp haben die ap ja die ap die haben nur pp da ist mit da ist mit
dotnet hosting nicht allzu viel net hosting ist eigentlich relativ relativ
teuer wenn man das managen haben will da fährste meistens besser du mietest die
irgendwas in der form oder oder in den server und macht das dann darauf ja wir
haben uns sogar das neue terminal schon mal eingeguckt im stream das neue
terminal ist recht nice hatte noch ein paar probleme kann mich jetzt aber nicht
mal dran erinnern was die probleme waren die wir im stream gefunden haben ich
glaube ich glaube bestimmte tasten ging ging nicht ins terminal durch irgendwie
sowas wie fandet ihr eigentlich mal wie toll chok ich fand ich fand den ja
massif lull
also wo man immer richtig günstige sachen findet aber das ist dann auch
dass man bezahlt low end und man kriegt auch low end das hier das ist eine coole
seite dafür weil man wirklich richtig günstige sachen haben will nice toast
brot brot abonniert stufe 1 dankeschön poch also die seite ist immer ganz
praktisch wenn wirklich low end preise und low end haben möchte dafür da kann
man sich jetzt zum beispiel irgendwie in den irgendwie storage oder so raussuchen
weiß es gerade nicht mal wurde oder wo stand in der storage offers storage
kvm ssd vm 250 im monat und so dinger linux guck mal sieben euro für pro
terabyte und 55 dollar für ein terabyte um drauf das wobei das geht das geht
noch billiger es gibt mittlerweile auch geschaertes
storage hosting also sprich wo du hinter einem natt bist beim anbieter und keine
externe alpima hast und sowas
wenn man das braucht nut storage stil zwei terabyte für
irgendwie 57 also das lohnt sich mal auf der seite zu gucken
wenn man wirklich billiges zeugs haben will dementsprechend ist halt auch die
quali oftmals also man kann jetzt da nicht super performance erwarten was ich
finde was der beste anbieter ist wenn man einfach mal einfach mal eine vm haben
will es sind die hier die sind aber nicht die sind aber nicht nicht super billig
aber wenn man einfach eine online vm brauchen was auszuprobieren finde ich
die hier am besten die dinger haben übelst wums also performance mäßig sind
die ziemlich gut und es ist super einfach also wenn man wenn man wirklich
nur mal online vm braucht zum ausprobieren sind die eigentlich am
besten finde ich es gibt ähnlich gute ähnlich gute
alles ist schon da ist kannst du für fünf euro im monat mit billig vm links in
linux vm und gut ist es ist wirklich cool einfach angelegt zack create maschine
ist da wofür kann man das dann benutzen das ist du hast dann einfach eine linux
mit einer public alp da kannst du alles drauf machen was du willst
das sind ganz normale vms du machst den account sagst hier create oder hast du
mit einem klick ne vm mit einem klick ne vm wir können uns ja mit github einloggen
ach fuck ich bin ich nicht eingeloggt ok können wir nicht oder hat einer die
emotes entdeckt obwohl du hast du direkt ne vm und kannst alles damit machen was
du willst die musik jetzt einmal übelst aufgedreht oder so
egal poc nutzt eigentlich vpn aktuell nicht mehr ich habe die ganze zeit immer
open vpn verwendet also eine ganze zeit lang jetzt aktuell schon eine weile nicht
mehr um mich mit meinem smartphone das kann ich euch mal zeigen das ist eigentlich
eine ganz coole konstruktion ganz coole konstruktion ich habe sie mal eine weile
halb ich open vpn verwende dass ich von meinem smartphone mich daheim einloggen
kann um unter anderem auf meine heim automatisierung sache richtig mlg musik
ja das kx imo das kommt alles noch ich habe jetzt irgendwie 18 imo slots oder
so ja da habe ich verwenden mich vor meinem smartphone mobil einloggen zu
können und dann zum beispiel auf meine heim automatisierung zugreifen zu können
und sowas dafür ist open vpn richtig praktisch gewesen
die musik geht mir aber echt auf den sack
ja das geht jetzt irgendwo
so und jetzt mache ich das ganz anders weil ich muss eigentlich selten von
wirklich von vom smartphone auf meine heim automatisierung zugreifen um
irgendwas zu machen ich will aber meinen standort
tracken also ich möchte tracken wo mein oder es aber wo mobilgeräte sind will
ich tracken weil ich ja reagieren möchte zum beispiel wenn ich auf dem
heimweg bin dann will ich wissen positionsdaten von meinem von meinem
iphone will ich die positionsdaten wissen dass mein heim automatisierung
checken kann okay ich bin auf dem weg heim oder von daheim weg und da kann ich
dann drauf reagieren so und das mache ich jetzt folgendermaßen es gibt es
gibt eine app die nennt sich und tracks das ist im prinzip ich weiß nicht was
das was das kommerzielle gegenstück ist wahrscheinlich google maps die tracking
funktion von google maps wahrscheinlich
das ist eine app hier sieht man ganz gut genau das jetzt auf dem iphone es ist
eine app da kannst du verschiedene server einstellen an die du deine
positionsdaten schicken willst und jetzt ist natürlich die frage wie kriege ich
die daten von meinem handy mit on track also auch noch das tracking schickt einen
server jetzt heim zu mir in das heim und die heim automatisierung rein weil ich
habe keine verbindung von mobil daheim so und dafür verwende ich das kann ich
auch nur empfehlen cloud mq tt das ist ein message pro also so message message
q da kann mein mobil mobil app die on tracks app kann quasi die sachen
einfach reinpumpen das ist das läuft online bei dem anbieter um ein heim
automatisierung system holt ruft sich das dann ab und so habe ich immer ohne dass
ich eine aktive verbindung von außen nach innen in meiner zweit brauche habe
ich immer die aktuellsten positionsdaten von zwei mobilgeräten was wirklich
praktisch ist was kostet eigentlich den gebrauch des iphone 6 kosten so was
die kleinere variante kostet billiger
was ist das so teuer das ist fünf jahre alt oder so warum ist das so teuer
aber das sechste kriegt er echt nicht ich habe da noch ein sechster also ich
habe jetzt jetzt habe ich den xxr aber ich habe noch in den sechsten grad da
oder habe ich in 6s weiß ich gar nicht wo habe ich wo habe ich überhaupt liegen
wo ist es warte mal was ist das für eins ich muss mal kurz gucken ich weiß gar
nicht ob es in 6 an 6s ist
woran erkenne ich denn das steht es drauf bei mir steht einfach nur iphone
hinten drauf ja habe ich wildshadow wenn dann s ist steht s hinten drauf nee nee
steht kein s ist normales iphone 6 heißt dass ein iphone 6 bekommt kein ios
13 mehr sehe ich das richtig das wäre aber ganz schön zack
aber scheiße also ich meine juckt mich jetzt nicht mehr großartig weil ich hab
jetzt einen xr aber das ist doof gut ist es fünf jahre alt oder sechs jahre alt
und ein 6s was kostet ein 6s ich gucke mal ebay gib handy alter gib handy ich
gucke bei ebay klein anzeigen ich gucke jetzt bei ebay klein anzeigen und dann
schreibe ich jeden an was letzte preis iphone 6s so was letzte preis
alter was letzte schütze dich vor bedrückung hole artikel persönlich ab garantiert in
frankfurt gehe ich nicht zu irgendeinem dude hin und hol mal mein handy ab da
wäre ich noch beklaut oder so auf dem weg
jetzt ja was nein ich melde mich jetzt nicht an okay ebay klein anzeigen kaube
ich nichts mir zu blöd man in 6s warum sind iphone so übertrieben teuer ich
meine man kriegt ein neues was was ist das was ist das kleinste iphone das neue
einstiegspreis
warum ist die apple webseite wieder so hässlich und so und so web 5.0 ich und
was ist ein guter mobiltarif aktuell also nicht für mich ich habe ja ich habe ja
mein mein zeug schon
aber so für einsteiger
du hier von iphone 4 trade in
zählt aber ein 6er für ich mein ich kann mein 6er nicht trade in weil der
6er mir nicht gehört
aber ich könnte ja drauf spekulieren dass sie vergessen dass ich noch ein 6er
habe und das 6er trade innen
kann ich kohle sparen ok no habe ich nicht ok 699 das ist in euro wahrscheinlich
das gleiche kann man kann man apple de nicht die stelle ich in die preise 1
hier aber warum kostet es in euro warum kostet es in euro wieder 100 euro mehr
das ist so dass es sagt so die dollar die dollar euro umrechnung eigentlich
müsstest du in euro weniger bezahlen als in dollar gut da kommen noch ein bisschen
taxes und geschiss und alles drauf aber warum kostet es in euro schon einfach mal 100 mehr
warum kann man nicht einfach sagen es kostet das gleiche das würde ich noch
verstehen feierst du vscode auch so sehr wie ich max ich finde das ich würde
sagen ich würde es nicht übertrieben feier aber es ist ganz ganz nett ja ich
ich persönlich mag ja wim immer noch am liebsten leider kann man damit viele
sachen nicht ordentlich machen
aber rein von der bedienung her gefällt mir am besten ok farbe product red
geht weiß schwarz will ich haben 64 g 799 hat aber gucken wir mal das aktuellste
iphone einsteiger gerät kostet 800 euro warum zum teufel soll ich 200 euro oder
so ausgeben also in den viertel vom preis denn denn drittel vom preis nee denn
was sind das
zwei fünftel vom preis
für einen fünf jahre jahre alte smartphone 3 achte vom preis ja ich
wollte jetzt nicht genau rechnen aber 25 kommt auch ganz gut hin oder
wie viel ist 2 durch 5 0,4 big brain alter iphone slow nicht ja alter was ist
mit der musiklose ist ja mal mega scheiße
ja ich habe auch schon das wenn wir es vscode plugin verwende das macht es
angenehmer
ja das schon besser entspannter
auch mit leute ich muss gucken ob ich irgendwie selbst vergessen habe der
sebaro den hatten wir schon ja also irgendwie gesteuert soll man angenommen
ich würde mir das kaufnummer mal angenommen theoretisch ja da ist ja
noch nichts dabei was für einen mobil funk anbieter lohnt sich denn aktuell
gerade auch huge rate mit neun leuten hier poggers
willst du den iphone bestell ja nicht für mich ich habe ja schon also ich habe
ja gerade noch noch ein 6 und das muss ich aber wieder zurückgeben und dann
jetzt habe ich nix eher wenn sobald ich es mal in betrieb nehmen was was für
den mobil anbieter ist dann gerade gut was was würdet ihr dann so empfehlen
was gibt es dann zum beispiel kong star gerade
ich brauche im prinzip eigentlich so gut wie nichts also ist ja nicht für mich
ist ja einsteiger einsteiger handy ein einsteiger gibt handy alter tarife
weil letztes meine mutter gekommen hat gesagt sie will ihr altes die hatten
auch so ein uraltes siemens klapp handy so was so ein ding hat die noch so was
so was hat die noch kann euch das vorstellen dass man sowas in 2019 noch
verwenden kann alter clocks xr fack
das ist halt so und so ein ding hat die noch so und sie wollte jetzt auch ein
smartphone und ich dachte mir erst ich frage mal auf der arbeit ob man nicht
vielleicht die alten iphone 6 irgendwie günstig bekommen kann weil damit da
geben jetzt ja gerade hunderte leute iphone 6 ab oder dachte ich mir
ja vielleicht aber wenn es kein ios 13 kriegt ist kacke
ok was gibt es denn hier so schön ist all net flat ok telefoniert eigentlich
so gut wie nie fünf gigabit aber 20 euro im monat gibt es nicht
irgendwie billiger dann eine fairflat
was der flat 2 gigabyte
und wie viel wie viel hongstar ist was würdet ihr denn empfehlen
ich habe wirklich kein platzen schimmer von mobil anbietern was würde denn
für mobil anbieter empfehlen was simple tell all die talk check 24
vergleich ok smartphone tarif vergleich gucken wir mal check 24 tarife penny
erstmal zu penny handy gewünscht nein datenvolumen aber ab eingehe tarife für
junge leute nur bis zum alter von 28 ohr ne das glaub ich nicht
vertragslaufzeit ehrlich gesagt habe ich habe ich keinen bock auf 24 monate
aber schauen wir mal inklusive minuten telefonfeld eigentlich ist es egal
telefoniert so gut wie nie wahrscheinlich schon gar nicht mit dem
handy
jule berät uns die fragen sich welcher tarif zu ihnen passt gemeinsam finden
wir das beste angebot ja jule dann schieß los
torsten auch der torsten meldet sich zurück haben sie fragen sie reichen
uns innerhalb einer minute steve oh steve steve hat keine gute bewertung
samira samira hat gute bewertung ich weiß zwar nicht warum ich da anrufen
sollte aber die leg da ist jule wieder ok ich glaube wir kriegen das auch ohne
die ohne die hin lte smart 100 ich finde die seite total
unübersichtlich oder geht es bloß mir so
ok was habt ihr eben halt all die talk die talker wenn ich so fotos schon sehen
auch die pakete prepaid das finde ich bestimmt toll und prepaid lohnt sich
halt wahrscheinlich null vor allem wozu sollte man prepaid machen
wozu ja das ist prepaid und trotzdem 12 euro im monat bezahlen ist halt next
level big brain
7 9 90 pro vier wochen was hat es mit prepaid zu tun
freenet funk freenet funk sowas gibt's wusste gar nicht das freenet
soll das sein doch in der app oder
was alles gibt das ist voll du kaufst es mit gut haben und nach vier wochen
hört es auf und du kaufst es neu ja ja gut aber aber dann verfällt ja mein gut
haben wenn ich es in der zwischenzeit nicht gebraucht habe
ich speichere mir das mal guck jetzt erstmal all die talk was haben die dann
da tarif details kombi pakete paket es 7 9 90 das ist top
einmalig ok
7 9 90 das ist doch das ist doch gut
das ist doch eigentlich ganz nice oder 8 euro im monat 2g das reicht ja
und so viele gespräche was was haben die was freenet funk ich gucke mir das
gleich mal an das reicht auch ist halt auch tun es ok sagt auch tun es ja geht
so ok warum sagt auch tun jetzt wir sind ja in der stadt wir sind ja hier in der
stadt ja die ist ja nur hier in der stadt unterwegs die denke ich nicht dass da
probleme gibt ok wann wie kann man das kündigen kündigungsfrist ist es auch
einmal im monat kündigungsfrist 0 also ich muss ehrlich sagen ich finde die
diese also das all die flatting sieht gar nicht so gar nicht so doof aus ich
meine mal hier 2g datenvolumen reicht ihr locker aus
flatrate gut sms verschreibt sms kein mensch schreibt mehr sms das heißt da
muss ich ich ich will da ich will kein neues iphone kaufen aber die brauchen
ein iphone die brauchen unbedingt ein iphone weil wir haben jetzt beide daheim
massig android geräte aber wo sie mit abstand am besten klarkommt und wo wir
dabei im thema sind dass nups tatsächlich ganz gut mit apple klarkommen
man kann mit apple oftmals wenig machen an vielen stellen also fallen was
automatisierung angeht dass sie am besten damit klarkommen das heißt die
brauchen ein iphone
was kostet ein iphone 8 was ist das letzte iphone mit home button
was ist das letzte iphone mit home button wisst ihr es achter
alle 400 euro fack ist das so teuer
ich darf das mit dem bediener freundliche ich auch nicht ehrlich gesagt aber ich
sehe halt dass es so ist
ok 16 g reicht noch teurer
apple se was ist ein iphone se
was ist denn an apple se 6s aha ja das doch gut ist schön günstig
senior ist das immer noch aktuell ist das immer noch aktuell
ein sechser ist gut genug in sechser kriegt kann 13 also ich brauche auf
jeden fall die muss auf jeden fall ios 13 kriegen auf ihr händi auf jeden fall
ich kann euch auch sagen warum mit ios 13 gibt es background tasks und
background task brauche ich um beispielsweise die türklingel und die
kamera an der außenwand wenn einer klingelt ordentlich bedienbar zu machen
auf dem händi weil du kannst ich ich hatte ich hab es nicht öfters erzählt
du kannst halt unter ios nix gescheit automatisieren
und jetzt mit ios 13 geht es halt zum ersten mal dass du im hintergrund quasi
in iphone dinger abrufen lassen kannst
achter geholt also achter gibt es ebenso 64 g ist aber ganz ist trotzdem
ganz schön teuer ich meine muss ich das mal reinziehen das ist das vor vor
vorletzte oder so vor vorletzte ist das vor vorletzte iphone 8 und es kostet
immer noch die hälfte von dem neuen jumper 2020 dankeschön 6s oder se würde
den deckel reichen denke ich auch ist das aber das se das se muss doch noch
aktuell sein weil es gibt doch nichts vergleichbares von apple aktuell oder
iphone
den android hol ich nicht für die außerdem ist es schöne bei apple
geräten da kann sie mir wenigstens ein messer schreiben
okay das se ist anscheinend vergleichen ja se
man kann das se noch nicht mal offiziell kaufen ja was ist denn was ist dann von
apple was ist denn von apple aktuell die die low budget variante hast du nicht
ein gutes dient doch doch ich habe ein iphone xr aber ich suche für meine
mutter was was 10r xr ich habe das heißt ich ja aber mein budget mein
budget handy kostet 700 euro das ist doch keine alternative zu dem handy was
150 kostet das ist doch ist das apple logik achter kaufen ja ich glaube auch
6s kannst du nicht mal kaufen eben da kannst du auch noch mal kaufen hier
achter
ne siebener gibt es nicht aber können mal gucken ja 250 gibt es gibt es das mit
16 g ne gibt es nicht 32 g 250
hier
ich meine
ich mein ganz ehrlich
das andere kostet 800 also das sind 200 270 euro unterschied und es hat ein
home button dass es ein home button hat finde ich wichtig weil ist halt
bedienung gewohnt vom ipad das ipad hat ein home button
naja gut was auch immer ich muss mal gucken also ich rechne jetzt mal so grob
über den daumen über den daumen gepeilt wäre ich wahrscheinlich ungefähr 600
euro ausgeben mussten für das iphone und irgendwie 8 euro im monat für einen
halbwegs gescheiten tarif ich meine es geht doch das geht doch dafür dass es
dann nicht mehr mit ihrem komischen siehmanns handy darum hantieren muss es
doch nicht verkehrt dass 6x das 6s kriegst du noch neu für 299 aber nicht
mal bei apple sondern muss ich mal gucken bei irgendeinem bei irgendeinem shop dann
in 6s würde ich mir auch wäre auch okay wird auch dicke reichen ich mein hauptsache
hauptsache hauptsache 13 du hast ja das youtube mani nähe ich hab ich hab das
twitch subscriber mani macht es jetzt wie dings hier korean savage war einfach
ein spendenvideo dass wir unbedingt ein neues iphone brauchen weil sonst ganz
ganz passiert ganz ganz ganz ganz schlimme dinger und wenn dann wenn ich
dann das geld eingesammelt habe dann mache ich dann ein video mein neuer
lifestyle vom strand oder so mein neues gamingzimmer war ich dann dann sage ich
dabei ja moment leute das hat nichts mit dem geld zu tun was ihr gespendet habt
das geld mit dem was ihr gespendet habt natürlich da überhaupt nicht
reingeflossen das timing war einfach echt blöde bei dem
zeig mal den vertrag für internet dings ja all die all die talk war das hier
guck das da das da haben wir gerade entdeckt dennoch 300 euro für vier
jahre alt das teil echt brutal ja finde ich auch ich meine für für 300 euro
kriegst ein relativ gutes android smartphone neu jetzt natürlich jetzt
irgendwie kein was sind angesagt galaxy dingsbums oder one plus noch was
neues aber war halbwegs gescheites ja neues das schöne an android ist halt
dass man so viel automatisch machen kann was unter apple nicht geht und
deswegen deswegen will ich auch unbedingt als 13 haben ich habe mir das
eben schon überlegt in fakt nicht heißt nicht mehr workflow oder wie heißt
denn das jetzt shortcuts oder shortcuts ios 13 wir haben jetzt background tasks
und ich werde das so machen du kannst du kannst das nur einmal alle minuten
anwerfen diese background tasks thomas cool 110 subscriber
kennst du ist ja kenne ich mag ich aber nicht so weil es ein ziemlich großes
delay hat wenn man was wenn man was haben möchte was einfach nur was tut
ab und zu mal ist das ok wenn man was hat was wirklich auch zeitnah reagieren
soll ist es doof beispielsweise meine haustür klingel über ist was namens
kann keiner aussprechen ist machen würde halt hätte übelst leck und wird
nicht funktionieren
konfigurieren das mal auf maximum 1600 euro oder so
nein max nachtgrün ja wenn schon brauche ich so die hässliche neue farbe
ist es ist ja ist ja es ist ja fast geschenkt ja fast geschenkt
ich meine ich habe etim kuk über dem bett hängen
da kann man schon mal in die in die kasse greifen ja woher kommt dieses nice
so dass es ein koreanes text-to-speech software konfigurieren wir den 5k
einberg was wir machen eigentlich wollte ich noch was einkaufen heute
was einberg pro nie was für ein einberg soll sich konfigurieren den da
ok ist das der mit dieser komischen tastatur ja das ist der diese
tastatur ist es schrecklich ok bei den anderen ist ist der ist der nicht
teuer genug oder was ist ist da nicht kostet nicht genug
ist er nicht teuer genug nicht kostet kostet nicht genug
sag mal nicht das richtig ich soll für eine fucking wiega 48
ich sie überhaupt 48 so ein special ding oder dass es eben so ein special
zertifiziertes sonst was ding was kein mensch braucht
guck mal die normale kostet einfach 177 euro es ist doch nicht das ist da nicht in den ernst oder 5800
euro ich meine 2 terabyte ssd habe ich jetzt auch habe ich schon seit ein paar
jahren drin 1080 ti ist drin ok ich habe ich gebe zu ich habe nur 32 g
oder ich glaube ich habe sogar warum kostet der ram denn bitteschön so viel warum kostet
denn der ram so viel ram ist zurzeit absolut billig
der ram kostet nix normalerweise der ist verlötet er klar das nicht umtauschen das nicht selbst was
rein machen kannst warten ab ram kostet grad gar nichts und hier also gar nichts wenig ja ok
wir machen das mal speicher was ist da drin wir gucken uns gleich einen anderen eimer an
266 das ist jetzt irgendwie hyperspeed irgendwie so wäre oder so kann man nicht sagen genau takt
266 64 apple was ist da los habt ihr einfach mal eine null dran gehängt oder was warum soll
ich für apple ram 1000 also zusätzlich 1200 euro bezahlen wohingegen 64 g ram aktuell
250 euro kosten oder ok sag mal mein kind wie hier kostet ein bisschen mehr und das
sind einzeln modul moment das ist das ist einzeln modul das stimmt ja noch nicht mal
wir müssen kit kit müssen wir gucken packungsgröße was ist denn packungsgröße kit größe ja guck
mal die ram riegel wahrscheinlich ist es auch wenn es in auf hier am riegel drin 250 euro
ist das so teuer fack alter ist das teuer das ist das ist huge teuer das ist einfach zehnmal mehr
gut ok einmal pro war doch nicht teuer genug leute geht noch was da geht noch was ok da geht
schon mal 5500 euro los ja jetzt jetzt jetzt immer klartext hier es ist so teuer da könnte
sich montana black und das rechte auge noch den apple den apple tätowieren lassen passend zur
rolex krone soll man irgendwelche deals machen so teuer dafür kriegst du auch eine rolex ok 18
core interlex ok das braucht kein mensch wir sind mal wir sind mal realistisch denn 8 kehren
xeon 3,2 gigahertz ist absolut ausreichend und ist wahrscheinlich für das meiste sogar praktischer
als ach so und der boosted ok alter apple haben die den vergoldeten vergoldeten ram oder was
neben den 10 kronen der cpu preis macht überhaupt nichts aus im vergleich zum ram
alter 6000 für für ram ok moment wir waren wir waren das jetzt noch mal
kit was ist der unterschied zwischen kit größe und packungsgröße
ok ecc
mit ecc bebuffert und buffert ecc ja gut dann nehmen wir halt ein kit
ok also wir nehmen einfach zwei stück davon ok das ist schon teuer das ist schon ganz schön
teuer wenn immer einzel modul wenn immer 64 g ja easy easy einfach vier stück vier stück
davon rein und gut ist da werden auch nicht nur zwei sachen da werden auch vier ram module
drin sein ok also wir geben ungefähr 1000 euro aus es kostet 1000 euro bei apple kostet es 6000
euro für wahrscheinlich ziemlich genau den gleichen ram ok bern also von wegen an rolex
geht ab 10.000 los ein mehr klagt sich kaputt über 10.000 euro aber brauchen wir jetzt natürlich
noch eine grafikkarte ordentliche wobei die reicht eigentlich aber zwo teuerarbeit ssd sollte es
eigentlich schon sein das verstehe ich das verstehe ich ja also ich denke ich denke das
ist gerechtfertigt bei einem bei einem rechner für 13.000 euro da sollte das sollte keine halterung
dabei sein also das ist ja quasi schon komplett am unteren limit da kann man schon mal 85 euro
noch mal für die halterung verlangen denke schon und der witz ist halt wenn ich mir das kaufe
also ich kaufe bin ich ne ich sag nur das ist richtig knapp kalkuliert also wenn ich mir das
kaufen würde ich hätte keine ahnung was ich mit machen soll das video von snazzy labs zu dem
weser kit gesehen nee hast du link kommst mal angucken jetzt wo wir gerade schon beim leichten
apple bastion sind aber das ist schon krass ich meine ok was kriegt man im endeffekt einen
10 kern cpu das kannst du wahrscheinlich beim aktuellen reisen besser haben weiß gar nicht
was also acht kerne reisen sind ja nicht so das ding gibt es gab es gibt keine 10 kerne es gibt
mal 12 kerne äh äh äh wo ist deine übersicht
wo ist seine übersicht war nicht auf overview wo ist seine übersicht was es alles für cp reisen
3 cpus gibt wiki chip alles gibt ja ach moment ich muss nach 10 nicht ich muss ich in der reisen 3
ich muss nach 10 10 2 oder so suchen was muss ich da suchen dass ich eine ordentliche übersicht
finde wie neuste reisen cpus ja so kerne den brauchen wir reisen 9 3900 x 12 kerne ja so
das ist das passende ding also wir könnten uns wahrscheinlich also rein mal von der hardware
ja wenn wir uns den rechner zusammen bauen wollen der sogar noch eine ganze ecke leistungsfähiger
ist als dieses ding hier gut eins muss man den zugute halten die displays sollen wohl ich kann
das nicht aus erster hand berichten ja die displays sollen wohl ziemlich gut sein auch
standardmäßig ordentlich kalibriert aber für den preis kannst du dir irgendwie den ordentlichen
sagen wir irgendwie iso ist beispielsweise ganz gut bei irgendwelchen bildschirme die halt auch
korrekt sein müssen ja oder was gibt es noch lieber also da kann ich mir einfach noch ein
viel besseren monitor dabei kaufen oder ein ähnlich gut monitor dabei kaufen und bei die
schon wirklich gut sein sollen so also ich mein wenn wir geben wahrscheinlich sagen wir mal so
wir geben 3000 euro aus 3000 euro und da haben wir auch 256 g ram drinne mit 2080 ti
dann reisen 3900x und wir kommen mit 3000 euro locker hin krass das ist echt heftig also was
haben wir jetzt hier für ein video apple apple store genius bar broke
was ist das für ein benchmark was ist das für ein benchmark weiß das jemand
kein battlefield gta a gta
man kann der ram selbst rein machen ok das geht beim aktuellen bestimmt nicht mehr
was ist das für ein benchmark was ist das für ein benchmark was ist das für ein benchmark
das ist ein benchmark was ist das für ein benchmark was ist das für ein benchmark ein
Brain
Mechanik